محمود ما الصعوبات التي ستواجه اسرائيل
اذا استمرت بحرب طويله الامان دوما ما
هناك علاقه عكسيه بين بدايه الحرب
ونهايتها بالنسبه للدول التي تشن ذلك
الحرب وهي الراي العام هذه هي المعادله
هنا بدايه الحرب يكون الراي العام مؤيدا
لتلك الحرب سواء بسبب الغضب والانتقام الى
اخره لكنها ذات بعد عكسي وينخفض هذا
التاييد مع استمرار الحرب وزياده الضحايا
هذه هي الداله العكسيه بدايه الحرب
الضحايا يزدادون مع الزمن بالتالي العلاقه
عكسيه وقد اشار الخبراء الى وجود هذا
العامل بالتحديد في هذه الحرب على غزه
التي تشنها اسرائيل الراي العام لن يكون
بطبيعه الحال في بدايه هذه الحرب كما هو
باخرها وسيكون هناك ان تغيير في الراي
العام وبالتالي زياده طول الحرب تلعب ضد
الاهداف الاسرائيليه عاده وعاده ما تفضل
اسرائيل الحرب الخاطفه ولكنها لن تكون
كذلك الان l